مساء الخير
نحن واقفين بالاستراحه كان في شاب عم يدخن
قربت منه قلت له يا ريت تبطل الدخان تعرف
الدخان بضرب الصحه قال لي بالعكس دكتور في
دراسه اثبتت انه تدخين قليل منه بفيد
الصحه
ستي الله يرحمها كان عندها مقوله تنصحنا
دائما ناكل دهني
بتعرفوها ما في اطيب منا مشويه كان ستي
نظريتها بتقول انه اذا كنا دهنه هالشيء
بزيت المفاصل هلا ما بعرف شو صار بالمفاصل
تبعي من ورقه الليه بس الشيء اللي بعرفه
انه صار في عندي تراكمات
انا اسمي حياه سباعي يسعدني اكون معكم
اليوم
بقدم حالي كباحث باحث محترف يعني بشهاده
يعني حاصل على شهاده الدكتوراه في مجال
الكمبيوتر
المعلوماتيه
اختصاصي الدقيق هو الذكاء الصنعي بالذات
بالضبط الرؤيه الحاسوبيه ومثل ما قلت سعيد
بوجودي معكم اليوم
المفروض انه هو موجه لتنميه المجتمعات
المحليه بيركز على تجارب محليه وبعد ما
نخلص الخطاب راح تكون سعيد انه يتصور
فيديو وشاركه مع اصدقائي على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مشان يشوفوا صديقي او
ابن خالتي الالماني ابن خالتي الثاني
السويدي وصديقي الامريكي ومجموعه من
الاصدقاء والاقارب يلي صاروا منتشرين
بغالبيه بلاد العالم
وللاسف كثير منهم من اصحاب الكفاءات يلي
خسرناهم
لذلك اسمحولي تكون خطابي شوي لا محلي راح
احكي على التجاريه ايام ما كنت باليابان
اثناء الدراسه والعمل عن تجربتي لما كنت
ماليزيا عم بشتغل كمدرس باحد الجامعات
الماليزيه وراح ضوي شوي على التجارب
الدوليه وراح احكي كمان حتى استشهد بافلام
سينمائيه
البدايه حتكون مع فيلم اجنبي غير هوليودي
بيحكي عن بعثه المريخ او بعثه الهند
لاكتشاف المريخ
محفزه الفريد وصاحبه
السبب تسال الفريق المحبط واللي معتبرينهم
علماء درجه ثانيه تسالهم سؤال كتير مهم
متى ولد العالم او الباحث بداخلك طبعا
السؤال هذا بيرزعهم لذكريات الطفوله بتكمل
بتقول لهم
كلنا حلمنا بالعلم واصبحنا علماء لكن
سرقتنا الحياه وضعفت احلامنا وانشغلنا
بالحياه وصارت حياتنا تقليديه وروتينيه
لكن اليوم عنا الخيار اتبعوا شغفكم شغفهم
باخر الفيلم بوصلهم على المريخ او بالاصح
بينجحوا بانه يحطوا قمر اصطناعي في مدار
المريخ وبتنجح البعثه الفيلم الحقيقه
بيركز على الابداع المحلي وبيركز على
التنافسيه بين فريقين الفريق اللي حكينا
عنه وفريق تاني بقوده شخص من نفس البلد
لكن هو فخور بنفسه كونه اشتغل لفتره طويله
بوك
اله ناسا الفضائيه الفيلم كمان
بيحمل عدد كبير من الرسائل الرساله الاولى
هي انه الحلم ليس ما تراه وانت نائم الحلم
هو الشيء الذي يمنعك من النوم
الرساله الثانيه الاولى بطل الفيلم بيقول
لا يوجد علم بلا تجارب هون عم نحكي على
التجربه فاشله ادت الانفجار صاروخ ممكن
يكلف مليارات الدولارات
الرساله الاخيره والاهم هي اذا ما فائده
او لا يوجد فائده من كوني عالم ما لم اسخر
علمي لمنفعي بلدي خليني اتشارك معكم بسر
بجوز النجاح ببلاد الغربه بخصوص البلاد
المتطوره لما الانسان يطلع لبرا نسبيا سهل
اكيد في تحديات من نوع اخر تحديات
الاندماج بالمجتمع اللغه لكن بالنسبه
للامكانيات العلميه هي متاحه ومتوفره
وبالعكس كل ما بحثت وكلمه وصلتنا بكون في
تحفيز وبيكون في مصاري اكثر
ابحاثك لكن
في مشكله صغيره صحيح العلماء المهاجرين
بطريقه او باخرى بفيدوا الانسانيه بعلوم
حتى لو كانوا ببلاد اخرى لكن بيحرموا بلد
من شغله كتير مهمه الا وهي اقتصاد المعرفه
او خلينا نقول حصه بلدون من اقتصاد
المعرفه اقتصاد المعرفه هو اقتصاد اليوم
الاقتصاد القائم على المعرفه
هذا مثل ما بتعرفوا قوه الدول اليوم ما
عادت عسكريه بس بل هي اقتصاديه وبتعتمد
بشكل اساسي على الدراسات النفسيه
والاجتماعيه والاستراتيجيه
العلم صار داخل بكل شيء
داخل بالتسويق داخل بالرياضه داخل حتى
بصناعه نجوم التمثيل والترفيه وداخل حتى
بالوجبات السريعه يلي تعتمد نكهاتنا من
بلد لاخر من نفس الشركه على الاستبيانات
ومعرفه اذواق
الجمهور يلي ياكل الوجبه المعلومه اليوم
صارت سلعه كتير مهمه ومثل ما بتعرفوا تتهم
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بانها بتبيع هاي
السلعه بمبالغ عاليه خلوني اتشارك معكم
بمعلومه التقديرات بتشير انه الدول
المتقدمه تنفق سنويا مليارات الدولارات
على البحث العلمي اللي هو اساس اقتصاد
المعرفه الميزانيه مجموع الميزانيات يعني
مجموع ما صرف البحث العلمي بالسنه الماضيه
حسب
المنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه بتوصل
لحوالي واحد ونص تريليون دولار هون عم
نحكي على التريليون اللي هو 12 صفر
اقتصاد المعرفه
هو يعتمد بشكل اساسي على البحث العلمي
وليس التعليم اكيد التعليم هو شيء اساسي
لتمكين وتعزيز
اذا هو مهم لتعزيز التنافس والمعرفه ولكن
انا بعتقد او بشوف انه التعليم هو بطريقه
ما استهلاك للمعرفه لانتاج لها
اذا رجعنا للاقتصاد القائم على المعرفه في
له اربع خصائص اساسيه الخاصيه الاولى هي
التعليم القائم على التطوير والتفكير
والابتكار اذا التعليم مهم لكن ممكن
للتعليم التعليم اللي بحفز التفكير
البنيه التحتيه المبنيه لتكنولوجيا
المعلومات والاتصالات التحفيز ورياده
وتسريع الاعمال الخاصيه الاولى يلي هي
التعليم المعتمد على الابتكار والابداع
بتذكرني بواحد من الافلام كمان راح نرجع
لكم لفيلم هذا الفيلم شايفينه اسمه او
الحمقه الثلاث بيحكي عن هدول التلات رفقات
اللي بالنص اسمه رانشو هو شخص دائما بفكر
خارج الصندوق بيسعى انه يحفز رفقاته انه
يتبعوك شغفهم يدرسوا بالفيلم مقوله كتير
مهمه حفزني انا بالذات بقول لا تدرس ابدا
لتنجح ادرس من اجل الكفاءه الذاتيه لا
تركض وراء النجاح بل اتبع التميز والابداع
وسيلحق النجاح بك ما بخفيكم سر انا خلال
دراسه الجمعيه كنت بطريقه او باخرى
ما بدرس لحتى اتفوق او لاخذ علامات بدرس
الشيء اللي بحبه وبس وبتبع شغفي ما بتتبع
الشيء اللي
خليني احكيلكم على تجربتي اكثر لما رجعت
على سوريا بال 2018 اكيد ما كان البيئه
العمل هي البيئه اللي بحلم فيها نحن طبعا
بلد خارج من الحرب هالشي طبعا ما لازم
يخليني يوقف وما خلاني وقف سعيد انا
ومجموعه من الاصدقاء لنعمل جمعيه تهتم
بالبحث العلمي سجلنا هاي الجمعيه وحزنا
نقدم على منحه لمنظمه ونجحنا بدنا نحصل
على تمويل لبناء مختبر نوعا ما بحقق جديده
انا عم دور عليه هالمخبر اليوم صار مخبرين
بالتعاون مع مؤسسه ثانيه يعني احسنا نعمل
البنيه التحتيه يلي نوعا ما عم نبحث عنها
التحفيز موجود والحمد لله وعم نسعى لنسرع
ونعمل رياده للاعمال يلي هي مشاريع واحلام
الطلاب اللي نتمنى انه يجوا لعنا لكن
بتعرفوا شو اللي بينقصنا بينقصنا هدول
الطلاب او اصحاب الاحلام او اصحاب
الافكار اللي حابين يحولوا افكارهم
لمشاريع يجوا لعنا ونشتغل نحن واياهم لنح
ول احلامنا واحلامهم لمشاريع
الناس بتخاف من البحث العلمي بتفكر البحث
العلمي شغلي معقده البحث العلمي ما له
شغله معقده ابدا البحث العلمي هو كلمتين
بحث وعلم العلم فينا نعرفه ببساطه بانه
عمليه بناء او هو اسلوب منهجي وركزوا على
كلمه منهج اذا هو اسلوب منهجي لبناء
وتنظيم المعرفه على شكل تفسيرات وتوقعات
قابله للاختبار اذا الكلمتين الاساسيات
المنهجي والاختبار وهذا هو اساس البحث
العلمي بطريقه او باخرى هو نوعين
بحث اساسي هو الذي يولد المعرفه واللي
بشبهوا بالطفل الصغير وبحث تطبيقي اللي هو
هدفه استعمال المعرفه بطريقه مبتكره ربما
لحل مشاكل بطريقه غير مساكن غير محلوله او
حله بطريقه تانيه
اذا بدنا ننبسط العمليه اكثر فينا نقول
انه البحث العلمي هو عمليه انتاجيه تحول
البيانات الى معلومات اذا تلتقط جزء من
البيانات تحوله الى معلومات هاي المعلومات
يتم تحليلها لتحويلها الى معرفه واللي
بنستخدمها لنصنع قرارات
هون في نقطه كتير مهمه هي مربط الفرس اذا
رجعنا لهون متل ما شايفين انا لما باخذ
جزء من البيانات بحوله لمعلومات بطريقه او
باخرى المعرفه دائما المعرفه هي نموذج
شخصي او خريطه احيانا للباحث او للعالم
يلي عم يبني هاي النظريه او المعرفه ولذلك
برايي الشخصي انه المعرفه او اقتصاد
المعرفه اذا ما انطلق من نموذج معرفه محلي
هو فاشل وهاي اللي بنسميها نحن
ناشونال او ما يسمى مجالات الاولويه
الوطنيه
اذا رجعنا لخصائص المعرفه ورجعكم كمان
لفتره دراستي
خلال دراسه الدكتوره خلال دراسه الدكتوراه
كان في عندي تساؤل وات از بي اتش دي ما هي
الدكتوره طبعا الانترنت توصلني
لشخص دكتور ويمات مايت هو كان زميل بديك
الفتره ايام ما كنت عم بدرس كان اختصاص
الكمبيوتر هلا غيره وفي له خطاب كمان على
اللي مهتم بالبحث العلمي بنصحه ويشوفه
لانه حديث كثير حلو
مات او دكتور برايت بمثل المعرفه بانه هي
عباره عن دائره فالدار الدائره اللي
جايبينها قدامنا هون والحديث طبعا
هي مجموعه معارف البشريه نحن بالمرحله
الابتدائيه
والثانويه بنكون بمركز الدائره عم نتعلم
شيء عن كل شيء مجموعه صغيره من المعارف
لما ندخل بالدراسه الجامعيه نتجه باتجاه
معين اللي هو اختصاص تبعنا ويبلش الدقيقه
الاختصاص لحتى نوصل بطريقه اخرى من
ماجستير بالدكتوره لسطح المعرفه بنصير
نعرف كل شيء تقريبا من خلال الدراسه
المرجعيه عن اختصاص معين وهون بتبدا مرحله
الدفع يلي هي الدكتوره اللي هي بنسميها
اللي هي انه شخص يعمل انجاز علمي يعمل شيء
جديد ضيف شي للمعرفه البشريه طبعا طالب
الدكتوراه بشوف الانجاز تبعه ضخم كثير لكن
هو بالنهايه نقطه صغيره بدائره المعارف
البشريه بالنسبه
له من هذا
انه
فهمت ان شهاده
الاسواق دكتوره هو شخص بيحصل على شهاده
سواء هذا الشيء ما بخليه سائق سباقات
محترف حتى يكون سائق سباقات محترف لازم
يستمر بالتاهيل والتدريب بشكل مستمر وهذا
الشيء لازم يكون كمان على شهاده الدكتوره
لازم بعد الدكتوراه يستمر الانسان بالبحث
والانجاز ولذلك في عنا احنا درجات علميه
اللي هي استاذ مساعد واستاذ
خلونا نرجع للفكره الاساسيه اللي هي انه
زي ما استخدمنا العلم خدمه بلدنا ونكون عم
نفقد شيء كتير اساسي من خدمه بلدنا تجربتي
باليابان بماليزيا علمتني انه
البحث العلمي هو يا جماعه ذئب اكثر منه
ذكاء اكيد الذكاء مطلوب لازم يكون الشخص
ذكي حتى يحسن يعمل بحث علمي لكن الاهم منه
هو العمل الدؤوب بماليزيا
استفادوا من التربه تبعهم وزرعوا زيت
النخيل والذهب والعمل المستمر خلاهم
يحاولوا زيت النخيل لمنتج وطني استخرجوا
منه مستخلصات اساسيه من النفط نحن بسوريا
في عنا تجربتنا المحليه يلي هي الورده
الشامله الورده الشاميه كلياتنا بنعرفها
هي منتج او هي ورده زرعوها اجدادنا
واستخلصوا منها مجموعه من المواد اللي هي
كلياتنا بنعرفها ماء الورد الزهورات ومربى
الورد الزهورات والمنتج طبي والماء الولد
ومنتج تجميلي ربما صحيح هي المنتجات كلها
مانع مسجله بطريقه علميه مثل هلا بنسجل
الابحاث العلميه لكن بالنهايه هي حصيله
بحث وتجارب مو بس الورده الشاميه نحن
اليوم عندنا الحاجه ام الافتراء احنا
بحاجه ربما
لنخترع طاقات بديله او نلاقي طاقات بديله
بحاجه نخترع وقود حيوي مستخلص من مواد
موجوده ببلادنا ومتوفره ورخيصه بجوز احنا
بحاجه
الحصول على مواد اوليه للبناء اذا مواد
بناء مقاومه كمان مستخرجه من منتجات
بلادنا
كتير مهم نحط فرضيات صحيحه ونقوم بتجارب
علميه ونوصل للنتائج ونناقشه وننشر هاي
النتائج بمجلات ذات عامل تاثير مرتفع او
نسجل منتجنا الفكري بخلال برائد اختراع
واياكم ثم اياكم والامتحان او السرقه
الادبيه لانه هي تضعف البحث العلمي انسب
الجهد لاصحابه واستشهد به هذا اهم شيء
بالبحث العلمي واستمروا بهذه الدائره اللي
هي دائره البحث العلمي يلي قد تشمل تطوير
المونتاج
ومحاوله تسبيبه بالنهايه بدي اقول جمله
كتير مهمه البحث هو منهج منهج حياه لا
يختص به المتفوقون بل هو عمل الدؤوبين وبه
طرق الامم ابحث
[تصفيق]